una vida cultural paralizada durante
casi seis meses para la reapertura de
sus teatros y cines el gobierno de
francia quiere evitar las prisas se
planea una reapertura gradual con un 50
por ciento de aforo
este es el caso de su vez y en español
donde los espacios culturales llevan
varias semanas abiertos como aquí en
madrid para evitar cualquier transmisión
del hobbit se deben respetar las
distancias entre cada espectador en el
cine y el teatro y la sala se
desinfectan antes de cada actuación
los espectáculos a gran escala que
acogen a un máximo de 5000 personas
podrían reservarse para personas que
hayan sido vacunadas o que tengan una
prueba pcr negativa en cuanto a
restaurantes y cafés francia avanza
hacia un plan en tres etapas de cuatro
semanas cada una como se propuso a
mediados de marzo a los profesionales
del sector
primero la reapertura de los
restaurantes de hoteles luego las
terrazas ya que al aire libre el virus
se transmite menos una etapa en la que
todos los restaurantes podrían reabrir
pero con un aforo de 50 por ciento de su
capacidad y finalmente una última fase
de reapertura total pero con un
protocolo sanitario reforzado para poder
ir a estos lugares se están considerando
varias opciones primero se debe tener
una prueba pcr negativa o un certificado
de vacunación como sucede en israel la
segunda opción el establecimiento de un
código qr para poder rastrear a los
clientes en caso de contaminación una
medida ya en vigor desde hace varios
meses en australia algunos países
vecinos están empezando a relajarse
gradualmente es el caso del reino
tras más de tres meses de encierro acaba
de reabrir las terrazas de los pubs y
restaurantes en bélgica como en francia
estos lugares han estado cerrados desde
octubre estas terrazas normalmente
reabrirán a partir del 8 de mayo